SURE WE GET THIS INFORMATION WE
NEED IN A TIMELY MANNER.
>> CONGRESSMAN, THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US TONIGHT.
HERE WITH REACTION, OUR TWO
ESTEEMED ATTORNEY.
AN AUTHOR OF THE NEW BOOK
"TRUMPED UP."
GREAT TO SEE BOTH OF YOU.
JUDGE ELLIS, YOU KNOW HIM WELL.
I KNOW HIM WELL FROM A LONG TIME
AGO WHEN I WAS A LITIGATOR.
HE'S AN INCREDIBLY TALENTED
JUDGE.
SENIOR JUDGE ON THE EASTERN
DISTRICT.
HE JUST LAID INTO THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL'S OFFICE.
HE SAID, "I DON'T SEE WHAT
RELATIONSHIP THIS INDICTMENT HAS
AGAINST MANAFORT WITH ANYTHING
THE SPECIAL COUNSEL IS
AUTHORIZED TO INVESTIGATE.
IT'S UNLIKELY YOU'RE GOING TO
PERSUADE ME THE SPECIAL COUNSEL
HAS THIS UNFETTERED POWER TO DO
WHATEVER YOU WANT."
>>
>
>>THEY'RE GOING AFTER PEOPLE
LIKE MANAFORT AND FLYNN AND COHN
BECAUSE THEY WANT TO FLIP THEM.
THEY WANT TO MAKE THEM SING.
AS THE JUDGE PUT IT IN THEIR
STATEMENT, MAYBE EVEN MAKE THEM
COMPOSE.
I THINK I CAME UP WITH THAT
PHRASE.
COMPOSING INSTEAD OF SINGING.
THE ONLY DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THIS
JUDGE AND OTHER JUDGES IS THIS
JUDGE IS COMPLETELY AND TOTALLY
HONEST.
HE CALLS IT THE WAY HE SEES IT.
THE AMAZING THING IS HE CALLED
HIM ON IT.
HE SAID, "YOU CAN'T DO THAT IF
YOU'RE A SPECIAL COUNSEL.
YOU HAVE TO GO AFTER DIRECTLY
THE EVIDENCE THAT'S WITHIN YOUR
MANDATE.
YOU CAN'T BE FINDING PEOPLE,
CREATING OR EXAGGERATING OR
COMING UP WITH CRIMES, NOT IN
ORDER TO GET THOSE PEOPLE BUT IN
ORDER TO SQUEEZE THEM AND GET
THEM TO SING AND COMPOSE."
IT'S ABOUT TIME A JUDGE HONESTLY
LOOKED AT THE SITUATION AND
ASSESSED IT.
YOU AND I HAVE BEEN TALKING
ABOUT THIS NOW FOR MONTHS.
WE SHOULDN'T BE SURPRISED.
BUT IT'S SURPRISING AND
REFRESHING THAT A FEDERAL JUDGE
WOULD SAY THAT.
WHY DID MUELLER TAKE THIS CASE
OUT OF VIRGINIA AND TRY TO PUT
IT IN WASHINGTON, D.C.?
BECAUSE HE KNOWS THAT HE WOULD
GET MORE POSITIVE JUDGES AND
JURORS IN THE DISTRICT OF
COLUMBIA THAN VIRGINIA.
IN VIRGINIA HE'S GOING TO GET
JUDGES LIKE THIS WHO ARE
STRAIGHT.
AND SO CLEARLY THAT WAS JUDGE
SHOPPING AND JURY SHOPPING.
WHEN I SAID THAT, I WAS CALLED A
RACIST AND CONDEMN.
CONGRESSMAN CONDEMNED ME.
BUT I THINK THIS OPINION
VINDICATES WHAT I'VE BEEN SAYING
FOR A LONG TIME.
>> WE DO HAVE ANOTHER ASPECT OF
THE CASE THAT'S STILL IN D.C. I
THINK WE LOST HIM.
IF WE GET HIM BACK, LET ME KNOW.